want you to panic a blunt message to the
European Parliament from Swedish
activists Greta to America the teenager
has given the world a wake-up call with
her urgent appeal for climate action the
global youth movement she inspired has
shifted the climate change debate
forcing it both to the top of the EU
agenda and party campaigning ahead of
the bloc's parliamentary elections next
week so what is the EU done so far to
tackle the climate crisis in March the
European Parliament voted to ban
single-use plastics starting in 2021 as
part of sweeping legislation against
plastic waste that pollutes beaches and
oceans it's agreed a near total ban on
insecticides that have been linked to a
dramatic drop in the numbers of wild
bees honeybees and other pollinators the
EU Parliament is pushing to put cleaner
cars on Europe's roads by 2030 and it
wants to slash its greenhouse gases by
40% in the next 11 years some experts
say that's not enough but right now it
doesn't look like any single member
state will be able to meet that target
reason enough for protesters across
Europe to keep pushing for faster
climate action in Brussels to talk about
how these issues are shaping the
European election I'm joined now by Lisa
bottom in the studio she's a
representative for the Greens in the
German parliament good day to you thanks
for joining us you think that Germany is
falling behind other European countries
don't you now Germany is considered by
many to be a leader in environmental
issues but but you think it's it's not
yeah those days are gone unfortunately
and for example France proposed to us
let's do C to neutral in 2050 also one
week ago together with other European
countries eight European countries but
Germany didn't want to you know be part
of this so I'm very ashamed as a Member
of Parliament why why don't we join the
initiative okay what happened why did
Germany fall behind what went wrong yeah
I think it's a climate of fear also
because of the ride populace so for
example we have reach in our elections
in in autumn this year so the government
is afraid of talking about carbon tax
for example or about two facing out coal
but I think we have so many young people
on the streets and they want to be am
the one to have this not fear but to go
forward so this is what we should do
okay well what do you think Germany
needs to do to to get in step then with
these other countries you're saying that
that have the lead in Europe especially
in light of these elections yeah I think
we should do a carbon prize together
with the other European countries that
would be a good thing the carbon tax
carbon tax there are a 12 European
countries who do have that but Germany
is still behind so at the moment those
who want to protect the climate they pay
for the others who pollute the climate I
think it's not just I want to change
okay but but your critics say that
Germany only produces 2 percent of co2
emissions globally why should it then
bear the burden for reducing carbon
emissions yeah I think we're more
powerful than that because Germany is
really important country in the European
Union so
if Germany would be the front a pioneer
of climate policy the whole European
Union could be a climate of policy and
it's the third biggest emitter end of
co2 in the world the European Union so
together we could really do something ok
so it's all about the European Union
isn't it when it comes to carbon
emissions and attacks you mentioned
populist being a concern in terms of
environmental policy they could poll as
high as 35% in these EU elections that's
what some opinion polls are showing how
would that affect climate change policy
and environmental policy if there was
that type of strong showing for the
populace first of all I do hope that
many people will not vote for the
populist that why we have to you know
tell the people to go to the elections
to vote for an international movement
for climate protection and not for a
nationalist movement who's against
refugees and against free borders and
brittle liberal democracy so that the
first thing we have to do and yeah we
have to defend our democracy and our
values lissa bottom for us from the
greens in the german parliament thank
you very much for being here